Ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di Cucina Buttata, oggi tenteremo
di fare una cosa che in passato ho fatto
quando collaboravo ancora con Cucina da
Uomini, che è stata la mia prima
ricetta al microonde, ossia una Mug Cake
Una torta in tazza che tu butti all'interno
del microonde e in pochissimo tempo
riesci a magnarti. Il problema è che in
passato avevo fatto degli errori
perché avevo messo, non so che cosa fosse
successo sinceramente, ma di base alla
fine sbrodolava tutto da tutte le parti,
per cui a questa botta ho pensato di
cambiare leggermente la ricetta, renderla
secondo me ancora più buona e con molte
meno probabilità di fallimento. Quando si
tratta di mangiare chi mi conosce sa che
per me esistono tre cose importantissime.
La prima, deve esse bono, la seconda deve
essere veloce perché non riesco ad
aspettare, la terza deve essere con
ingredienti facili
Ci aggiungo pure una quarta, abbondante (Chef Rico)
Abbondante...e la quinta? Senso di colpa (Chef Rico)... A me piacciono tantissimo i dolci, lo si
capisce anche dal fatto che se voi
tornate al primissimo video che ho fatto
di Cucina Buttata, vedrete che la mia
faccia era la metà e non è un problema di
obiettivo, è che in questo periodo il
frigo quando io gli passo vicino lo sento
tremare "No ti prego no non lo fare, non lo fare!
Mi metterò a dieta anche perché a breve
arriva l'estate, non ne parliamo, mi sono
già depresso. E questa era la torta, una
torta all'aria...mamma mia...paradiso (Rico)
No ragazzi. Anzi paradiso, purgatorio e inferno (Rico). Si tutti insieme. Quindi per fare i check, buono. Ragazzi è
alla Nutella. Io se questa qui adesso la metto sulla
suola delle vostre scarpe dopo che avete
acciaccato la m***a saranno buonissime, quindi
non si può sbagliare. Veloce e calcolate
che prendiamo questa o lei se voglio
essere più figo, non lo so devo ancora capire
A seconda di spanatura direi che questa
qui è più interessante di questa, co questa
qui ci si può fare il bagno a un
chihuahua. Bellissima! E' velocissima
perché sbattiamo tutto qua dentro,
giriamo e la infiliamo all'interno del
microonde. Semplice, so veramente quattro
ingredienti a parte uno che ci siamo
dimenticati e che quindi stiamo
rimpiazzando con dello yogurt, perché
doveva esserci il latte. Questo plurale maiestatis (Enrico)
Gianmarco si è dimenticato il latte...Abbondante dipende
dal...dalla grandezza della tazza nella quale
la faremo, questa è più instagrammabile
e questa è più insta mangiabile.
E sensi di colpa a iosa. Per fare la Mug Cake alla
Nutella avrete bisogno ovviamente di
Nutella, zucchero, olio, yogurt al lampone
un uovo, della farina. Ho preso ispirazione
da the Baking Bomb
4 cucchiai di farina
Ragazza allora vi spiego
*risate in sottofono*
Ma da dove sta uscendo? Vabbè non dovrebbe uscire
niente, non dovreste sporcare moltissimo
la cucina. 3 cucchiai di zucchero, un uovo...3 cucchiai di olio. Secondo me dovevamo
usare tipo un olio di semi per renderlo
un pochino più leggero, invece stiamo
proprio usando l'olio extravergine di
oliva. Ci mancava solo che mettessimo
quello della macchina. La ragazza dice "Mettetene quanto volete
quanto vi piace", quindi diciamo 3 cucchiai...no? Tre cucchiai ma...A questo punto
iniziamo a girare...in teoria dovreste
andare tranquilli. Shakalaka shaka
Sta uscendo molto farinosa secondo me.
Guldo al parco. Serve semplicemente un
sacchetto e il c**o di Guldo
A questo punto loro suggeriscono di aggiungere il latte
noi non ce l'abbiamo, aggiungiamo un
cucchiaino più o meno di yogurt, mettiamo
un pochino di...cremosità (Rico)...cremosità esatto. Poi secondo me il fatto che sia al lampone non è nemmeno
malvagia come cosa. Nella sfiga in realtà
una fortuna abbiamo avuto, infatti ne aggiungo un
altro pochino. Vabbè io sto già facendo
di testa mia, questo vuol dire che il
fallimento è dietro l'angolo
E poi vi fate un bicipite ragazzi, cioè la
spalla vi esce così, sembrerete dei tennisti
a fine ricetta. A fine ricetta ti esce la panza così (Rico)
Prendetela bene bene dal
basso. Vogliamo provare a farne una nella
tazzina più carina? Riempio questa fino a qui
Questa qua. Il mio consiglio è quello di
fare tutto all'interno di una tazza
io invece voglio fare il figo e chi fa il fico deve pagare sempre un pegno. Già non hai
la stessa consistenza. Un minuto, non sono convinto
Ci sono buone probabilità (Chef Mario)...che venga un m***a!
Io non ho idea di cosa...non ho messo il grembiule!  Cacchio (Rico)! Madonna! Dai per l'assaggio (Mario)
Certo serviva per la preparazione (Rico)
Serviva per la preparazione...Sarà un fiasco, la ricetta sarà un fianco (Rico)
Ma che, che vuol dire? (Rico)...Questi sono quei
momenti in cui uno fa le cose...fatte male vediamo (Rico)...La lasciamo altri due minuti
Comunque se lo rifai altre (Rico)...venti volte non mi viene
No ragazzi! Qualcuno può provare a farlo? Perché sennò sembro io pazzo che
magari e una c*****a e tutti ci riescono
Gianmarco non ci riuscirà mai! (Rico)
Gianmarco non riesce a metterselo manco così.
Cioè te hai fatto così...e infili la testa
Aspetta un secondo...Eh non è facile. Un altro minuto. Tu hai pure il testone c'hai. Si ma tu devi tirarla verso l'alto
Vai...Madonna! Tu sei fortissimo
No ma non è difficile. Tirala in alto e
infila la testa...e mi devo tipo infilare, tipo tartaruga...Eh guarda che non è terribile. Erri vai
Secondo me è più bello che tu cammini in avanti (Rico).
Ahhh bellissimo vai! Facciamo così lancialo. Vai, vieni verso di me. Io cammino...io cammino
Faccio io faccio io, forse devi andare più veloce. Ok vai. Vado
Non è molto invitante eh Rico)
Vabbè non è male oh (Mario). Si effettivamente...un buon odore dai (Rico)
Non posso assaggiarla senza il grembiule
Già dall'odore si sente che è una mattonata, è pesante
C'è qualcosa che mi ricorda tipo un Oreo (Rico)
Ho bisogno di un parere
Scappa!...E' buono
E' ustionante vero? No. Si. Nono. Scusate
Erri, se rimetto assaggi un'altra volta? No. L'ho sciacquato. Allora...porca miseria, ti brucia
Non toccate la tazza...è strana, posso dirlo? Schifosa non lo è ma credo
si sia...non è schifosa ma c'è un difetto enorme. Non capisco cosa...che stona
Secondo me è quello yogurt...secondo me si...quello yogurt de m***a ve?
Ci sta pure un barile di Nutella dentro cioè quindi proprio...eh ma non fa male la Nutella al sapore
E' quello yogurt ragazzi...questa col latte
Eh. Eh. Lo yogurt ce l'hai messo te però. Suggerimento, avete
presente la cosa che vi ho detto dello yogurt...
il fatto che sia al lampone non è
nemmeno malvagia come cosa. Infatti ne aggiungo un altro pochino. Dimenticatela
Che poi è pure buona.
Metteteci il latte, meno farina e meno
Nutella. Poi lo yogurt nel microonde è una mezza c****a
Se volete fare anche voi questa mezza c****a
non esitate...non scordatevi lo yogurt (Rico)
Non esitate a taggarmi su Instagram,
vi lascio nel mio infobox tutti quanti gli
altri posti dove mi potete seguire e
potete continuare a sentirvi più intelligenti
e comunque con una vita migliore
della mia. La prossima domenica sempre
alle 12 uscirà un nuovo video di Cucina
Buttata e fino ad allora che dire, in
bocca al lupo per tutto e vi mando un bacio. Ciao
Ingrassate ragazzi ingrassare